Oh glowy, glowy yes
AHH! AHH! AHH! AHH! AHH! AHH! AHH!
Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome to Blood Bath Bay now Blood Bath Bay is a horror game to be sure
Where you have to go diving down into the depths of the ocean and face some of my worst nightmares
I don't know exactly what's waiting for me down there at the bottom of the ocean, but I have a bad feeling
That it's going to be something horrible
And something that's probably gonna kill me dead which is very likely
Ohh (Nervous laughter)
(On comms) Topside to Donnie, come in Donnie?
Hi this is... "Can you hear us down there?" This is Donnie
"Send up two signals if we're coming in clear"
BOOP BOOP
Woah
"That's an affirmation, comlinks are established and operational"
Okay...
"Patching in the commander now"
"Alright, I don't need to remind anyone of the importance regarding this op, so just get it done quickly"
"And we'll be on hand for extraction, good hunting down there"
Wait, I think you need to remind ME of what the hell's going on down here-
(Character thinking to himself)
"It was like something from a damned horror show"
What was?
"Corpses were... Climbing out of their graves and feasting on the living"
Diving solo could be considered one of the more reckless things a person could subject themselves to
THEN WHY AM I DOING IT?
"Regarding the situation, it almost felt safer down here"
Huh?
"Peacefully"
HUH?
"Like the calm before a storm"
Well don't say that!
UHHHHHHHHH
I don't like this
I don't like this at all!
(More nervous laughter)
I- tuh- I definitely
Do not like this! Uh, I also don't like the perspective. It's making it things
(?????????)
Seem like there's things in the darkness yeah
What is that?
Do I need to be worried about that? Should I shoot that? I only got so many bullets should I be worried about that?
(Markiplier noises)
Okay
Now this game is made by
*Deep inhale*
Okay
(Commander talking again) "Remember, we're after those glowing sea snails. We briefed you on earlier"
"We're going to need no less than about thirty of those little buggers if we-"
THIRTY?
"Successful treatment"
Whuuuh?
(Back to character thinking) "I had read the dossier"
"These snails weren't usually so easy to find"
"Something about their mating season drove them from the rocks"
"Glowing bright to attract a mate"
"Little of it mattered, I had my own reasons for taking on this job"
(MARKIPLIER WHALE NOISES)
WHUT WAS THAT?
What are your REASONS?
What are your reasons SIR?
Okay, I got one snail. Yeah, I got a snail
Everybody be happy about the snail I got. Is everybody ecstatic about the SNAIL?
All right now. I don't know for a fact if there are things in the deep darkneUUSSS here...
But I have a funky feeling I have a funky feeling whoa hey Nemo
I have a funky feeling that if I find them they're gonna be crawling up my butt any moment now
Ohhh that looks bad
Where the heck?
Where in the heck am I?
Scootuhly doodly doodly DOO
WOAH EYY
Uh oh
Okay
(More Markiplier noises)
Why am I going this (COUGH) why am I (WHEEZE) why would I be going this way? Why did I choose to do this?
Also where am I?
Oh I know where I am okay. All right but I haven't
Ah-WhoOoOoOo
That was not enough sprint!
(Sharp inhale)
That was no enough sprinty doo!
(Markiplier noises intensifies)
(Markiplier laughs nervously, again)
I hate this...
Okay
(SNIFF)
Euh, god I gotta find thirty of these assholes?
Or maybe that was three and I was just hearing things
Maybe I may be hearing things when they're coming after me in the darkness, but
OOF
Aww, I do not like the way the world just warps around
Oh are those piranhas? No
(Scared Markiplier)
(Radio chic again)
"Donny, we're picking up that you are nearing the proximity to the Santa Anna Gulch. During the war this area was host to some..."
"Intense naval skirmishes"
"I know you're working with low visibility, but you might come across some leftover sea mines. If you do they can be set as checkpoints"
(Commander douch-bag)
Seeing as so many lives were lost logo started calling the area bloodbath bay. The name just stuck.
"And the name just stuck"
(STATIC)
Okay all right. Yeah! A checkpoint! That'll do me a lot of good! I'm real happy about the fact that I have a check point!
Okay all right. Yeah a checkpoint, that'll do me a lot of good. I'm real happy about the fact that I have checked boy
What's down here, in the death area? I see glowies...
What's down here in the death area? I see glowies.
Hey, hey ba. I don't like that. No I seem to have been stuke
All right, don't mind me- is that a pirate ship?
oh boy, what do we got oh
Oh boy! What do we got
OOOOOHHHHHHHHH
Thunk?
Okay guess he's not lethal all right. Well. That's not good all right
Just gonna skedaddle around that and go for the glowy that I saw over here
Somewhere
Glowy's gone
Okay, Oh, glowy, glowy yes
(Markiplier imitating a screaming monkey)
(Is awestruck)
That's a lot of moaning. Oh, bloOoOoOod, goOoOod
That's a lot of moaning oh, blood, good
Okay
Great
EEUUUHHHHHH
I saw another one over here.
(Markiplier moaning noises)
Oh god!
Oh, God
Okay I don't know where it went, but it is very gone. It is exceptionally gone
HEY!
Hey hey hey hey HEY HEY HEY HEY HEY HEY HEY HEY WOAH WOAH! AHHHHH!
OOHHHHHHHUUUUUUHH
I WHY?
OKAY, I guess I'm fine
I thought I saw something
What are you?  I don't like you. Okay alright maybe I'm out of, I'm out of gun
OOOOO what are you, I don't like you... okay alright? Maybe I'm out of, I'm out of gun
I'm out of gun and maybe the best option is just to run as far as I can run
Ohh b-
*BWWWAAAHHHHH*
WHY? Are you that?
Why?
Oh THAT'S why...
(Super quietly) Oh, okay... alright
Glowy yeah
Ooo, glowy... Yay! Yahoo!
Yahoo, I can kind of see them on the mini-map so that's good... I guess
Alright...
*BWAAAAAHHHHHHH*
Ooohhhhhhh
Don't like that
I don't like tha-
Hey-ho no, no, run now
Ah Yeeee-
AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH!
No, don't please. I'm too young to die.
No! Don't please. I'm too young to die
(Markiplier Laughter)
EHHHHH, EHHHHH, UHHHH,
Ehh, huhuhuhuhuhuh
I'm okay look a checkpoint. Oh
I'm okay look, a checkpoint. Oh, ah
Ah
You meant that literally you meant literally they're checkpoints, I thought you just met there were like no
NO NAOOOOOOO
NO
(Drowning noises)
I thought you just meant that they were landmarks
Okay, alright well got one
Got four
30 of the, oh now. I'm seeing more of them. Where were all them before
Thirty of these, oh now I'm seeing more of them
Where were all them before?
All right, whatever.
All right, whatever. Hop. No, that did not work
Hyuup
No that did not work
OHHHAGHHHHHHH
Alright
Ooop Hup Hup
AAAYYYYYYYAAAHHHHH
AAAHHHH!
Okay, hate that. I am X-ing as hard as I can. I am dead. Okay, I am very dead.
OHHHHHHKAY HATE THAT
Euhhh euhhhh
I am Xing as hard as I can
I AM dead, okay I am very dead...
Well oh I'm dead again, thank you
Okay alright, I don't think I need to press X to escape
But you know I'll keep that in mind you never gonna go away?
I saw (minor horse noises)
AHHH OOHHH, my GOD oh my god I'm ESCAPING!
Oh my God, oh my God, oh my God. I'm escaping. I am escaping.
I am escaping
Ahhhhh!
Tried my best I tried my best
Can you imagine being down here in the dark depths of the ocean hidden away from absolutely everything?
Can you imagine being down here in the dark depths of the ocean hidden away from absolutely
everything?
All you see is darkness, and death.
All you see is darkness
AND DEATH! AHH! I AM Xing! WHAT DO YOU WANT FROM ME?
I AM TRYING!
Euugghhhh
Euughh geez
Eugh
What can I do, I press X as hard as I can
What, do you want me to play with a controller? I'll do that...
Okay how do I sprint whoa what the heck e nice roll there, bud? I don't know how to, sprint
But I know how to combat roll and to be perfectly honest that's probably just as important
Ugh
Nope
This sucks
OH OH OH OH OH OOOOH OOOOHH
I can't run! I have no idea I have no idea how to run
I see well there we go I got a push down- uh oh
Hey, buddy. Hey grouper hey look. I see a shiny
Eeeeee why do I need 30 of these assholes?
There's no way
AAAAHHHHHHHH
I AM SORRRRRY
Fuuuuuuuck
That's my line (Markiplier giggles)
Fuuuuuck
(More whale noises from Markiplier)
How, how do I do that-
AAAAHHHHH!
OOOOWWWWWWKAY
You are a bag of
tits
and I do- oh, god, oh no, I'm gonna get a triple whammy
AHHH
(Sad Markiplier laughter)
WAAAHHH
Ohhh
(More sad Markiplier laughter)
(SNIFF)
(Even more sad laughter)
This game is impossible!
Try not to imagine they are in the darkest deepest depths of hell
AND EVERYTHING IS OUT TO GET-
Ahhh, I did the combat roll, haha
That does nothing!
UUAAAAAHHHHH
Ohhhhhh that one's just- that one's just impossible, oh my god
This game you can't win!
You can't win I'm flailing like a moron every time
I get snapped up in the jaws of the asshole fish
If my pathetic combat role ain't gonna do shit to me
It's like my worst nightmare wrapped up in a nightmare burrito. Oh my god
I can only hope that it's not directly in front of me
Maybe I could just afford the opportunity to roll into its mouth that the only thing that I can play for here
Maybe it's gonna be nice and swallow me whole
AHHHHHHH
I duh-
you have no mouth!
What are you!?
Oh you nightmare fish, AHH
Be careful, I might roll away from you.
(Markiplier Grudge impression)
Guuuh
Uh ohh, that's a problem
(Laughing) Welp
Didn't even come to that, now did it? Didn't even have OUUHH
Didn't have an opportunity to let me suck
You're just gonna let me
Squander around in fear and then die on my own
You bag of dough oh?
You big honking honking bag
AAAHHHH!
Oh ho fucking hell!
How did you do this?
It's imp- I am mash- I mashed as hard as I could mash
It's the sucker face dodge!
Pfff, (laughter)
UAAAAHHHHH
He's got no face
Uh oh well my thi- I think I'm probably boned
BOINK
Guys, I don't want to brag, but I think I'm doing pretty good
I huh I don't want to go out on a limb here, but I-
Ahh! AHH! AHH! ROLLLLL!
I tried you bull-horned bastard!
I'm alive, okay (Markiplier laughs)
UHHUHHUHH
Roll~ (More laughter)
We gotta roll for the bushes
(Strange Markiplier sounds)
There we go
Ooop
HAA! OHH! OHH! OHH! OHH MY GOD
Stop chomping on mah crotch like that please I don't- uh oh- I'm going exactly the way you were going so that's
Unfortunate for the both of us I'm gonna go back now because apparently I was going the wrong way no matter what
Thank you, yes please yes, okay. Thank you...
OHH!
ROLLL!
ROLLLOLLL
AHH RUN!
Hey running roll rolling run those are the only two skills that I know and neither of them are working
Heyyeeee
It's still behind me isn't it
ROLL INTO THE BUSHES!
ROLL!
I TRIED YOU'RE SO WEIRD okay, I guess we're fine then
I have no idea when my webcam broke
I have no fucking idea
But am I jus- wait, am I- wait, woah what?
Wait, heh, wait, Heh heh, wait
Wait a- hang on a techond
(???????????????????????????)
Second here, wait hang on I- heheh- I thi- there's something
Heh
I don't think- that's not
That looks like a foot
I don't think- I seem to be permanently dead and mr. Blubber face over there,
HUUUUUUH
All right anyway I guess that's enough for uhh
Blood Bath Bay, the game...
That's pretty difficult, I don't know how you'd get all of these things at the same time, but that is Blood Bath Bay
Thank you everybody so much for watching
If you want to play this game for yourself check it out in the description below
Let me know what you thought down in the comments
And as always, I will see YOU
In the next video...
bye-bye!
BWWWAHHHH
(TSHH) BAH, BUH DUM DUM (TSHHA) DUM
BWWWWUUUMMMM
BUH BAH DOO
(Epic techno music that cannot be replicated by mouth)
BWWWUUUHHHHHH
(TSHH) BUM, BAH BOO BUM, (TSHH) DUN
BWWEEERRRR, BWEEERRRRR
WUBBA WUBBA WUBBA WUBBA WIIIISHHHUUUUUUUU